eigentlich so heike was geben ich bin
der marcel und meine frage wäre
warum möchtest du eigentlich kein
youtube partner wäre nicht mein ich weiß
du hattest schwere probleme mit
koteletten so aber so was ja auch bei
fresh torge also du müsstest ja dann
eigentlich nur deine videos auf dem auf
meinen account machen oder auf extreme
kommt mir oder so wurde keine probleme
hast sagen den leuten halt einfach sagen
dass die dann
den anderen abonnieren sollen einerseits
nicht so großer aufwand bei burger hat
es dann doch geklappt
also was der eigentliche grund warum du
das nicht machen willst also bist du
nicht so der kommerzielle tipp oder
willst du einfach auf dem wacken bleiben
yunus gehen also warum bin ich kein
youtube partner ja das ist schon diese
copyright geschichte dass es aber auch
also ich möchte mich nicht einschränken
lassen und so wie ich das von anderen
youtube partnern höre ist es dass die
halt wirklich sich an total viel halten
müssen egal ob den video von jemand
anderem in ihrem video einbauen müssen
die verdienen hat sozusagen über google
geld über google ads und müssen für
alles eine genehmigung holen egal
welches lied sie benutzen das ist mir
einfach zu kompliziert ich möchte das
video jetzt gerade in diesem moment
hochladen ich möchte das nicht großartig
darüber nachdenken ob ich habe irgendwie
copyright verletzt ich achte jetzt schon
mehr darauf dass sich jeder benutzer die
vogue eine große firma dahinter ist
nämlich dann verklagen könnte ja aber
ich möchte das einfach nicht und ich
möchte auch keinen neuen kanal machen um
die ganzen videos da wieder hin zu
transferieren ich möchte einfach meinen
mist machen und dann sofort online
stellen und mich großartig gedanken
darüber machen und ich möchte auch kein
geld damit verdienen war
das würde mich auch irgendwie nerven
wenn dann plötzlich in meine videos
werbung eingebunden wird so das will ich
nicht also ich sehe keinen vorteil darin
youtube partner zu sein außer dass man
vielleicht auf der hauptseite gefeatured
wird wie bescheuert aber das brauche ich
ja nicht weil ich ja eh schon oft
richtung genug leute haben die
abonnenten sind und das reizt mich
irgendwie nicht youtube partner zu
werden ja also ich sehe da nur schlechte
dinge